not all instead that makes it appeal to
the visual senses but let's let's say
that most of it does so its might seem
unnecessary or necessarily Elementary
just to say so but sometimes it's worth
reminding ourselves that yeah art is
something meant to be seen primarily
that the the appeal that makes to our
intellect and emotions our attention is
is achieved through through visual
stimuli and it's that's a different
animal then there are other things in
writing or music the eye is capable of
incredibly subtle perceptual
distinctions that are that happened on
an unconscious level so the the act of
looking consciously is really partly a
matter of paying attention to what it is
we notice when we when we really look at
something because the another way
putting it is is to think about drawing
if you've ever taken a drawing class or
you've ever even read a book about how
drawing is taught the first most
elementary lesson is usually a
demonstration of the difference between
what you see in front of you and what
you think you see very invariably the
the first attempts at drawing something
from live from from perception
invariably involve distorting what's
actually in front of you because the
brain intercedes with the eye
and gives false information for example
we know that the you know the head has
two eyes a nose and a mouth so we will
we will draw it that way even if in fact
we don't see both eyes equally or we
don't see you think on our point of view
we'll see a partial representation of
what the brain thinks of as reality so
this is a long way it went a long way
around saying that a way to approach the
visual visual world is to take in the
information and let it work on your
cortex without well it's possible to say
without but well while trying to stay
neutral in terms of what what we think
we know because part of I would say part
of the confusion surrounding
contemporary artists that it's it's we
know it's laden with meaning and where
we go to it intent on ferreting out the
meaning which sometimes happens in
advance of doing the actual looking when
I say that ideally one should approach
all right with the visually neutral
I'm screen that visual neutrality is it
is of course a kind of cultural
impossibility we all would none of us
are neutral and nor could we ever be and
probably nor should we be when I say one
should approach our with a neutral eye
what I mean is to simply log in your
brain to log what's there physically in
terms of what was made in advance of
reaching for what the thing might or
might not mean so that
yeah if you're looking at some portrait
let's say which up what a support
reporters a painting on a face of course
the face is the subject but the the way
the face is painted the way the portrait
is presented to us and its specificity
is more important as art than the who
would supported of it's probably not
possible to be art without the filter of
seventeen different kinds of cultural
filters I don't think that that's that
would be probably that would require the
equanimity of a Buddha however what I'm
what I'm suggesting and what I'm
advocating in the book is simply to
devote some of one's attention to the
physical fact of what is in front of us
the physical fact of what was made how
it was made what materials were used the
the how was it done kind of question as
opposed to what it's a representation of
it this kind of attention is what used
to be called formalism which i think is
a little bit of a misnomer but it there
has been I think I'm fairly or unuseful
II demonized as something either
culturally aloof or simply not not
interesting but the first principles of
any are of any feet in any field of any
art form music architecture literature
the first principles being how was it
constructed what is constructed of those
are the kinds of perceptual questions
which in any one
can ask themselves to be aware of
without any cultural training the
impulse to make artists is is a
mysterious one it still remains
mysterious after many millennia
what is that impulse of that compels
someone to make an image of something a
two-dimensional surface or a
three-dimensional form for that matter I
often think that the way to approach our
is to imagine doing it for oneself
imagine what is what are the steps
involved to make that thing that you're
looking at what would what would you
have to do if you were going to make
that whatever that that is even things
as banal as getting on the subway to go
to the art supply store what do you have
to buy what are the materials you have
to buy what kind of space do you need to
be able to make that thing in in other
words I one way to think about art is to
imagine yourself as the artist imagine
yourself as the maker put yourself in
the artists shoes so to speak and
imagine the steps that one would have to
go through very much like when you read
over a cookbook and there's an
illustrated step-by-step recipe that you
follow first you have to put these
ingredients in then you have to put heat
preheat the oven
sometimes imagining the the banal task
like steps involved in making something
helps us to appreciate what it is that
was made instead of looking at the the
result and it come in a completely
meaning blatant kind of way and we don't
really I mean I really I'm not to strain
it to the breaking point but I if the
cooking analogy is has any use at all we
don't we don't ask of a PI what does it
mean we just ask that it tastes good and
then if you're interested in how it how
it stacks up next to other pies and then
you get then you might ask yourself what
was the recipe and what were the
ingredients and what's different about
those from some other ingredients all
this is a wet another way of saying that
art is something that someone made and
that the human aspect of the making part
of it is I think the the place where one
can reliably go to both find a
connection to the art and also to get
closer to whatever the artists emotional
field might be